um we are uh taking calls via discord
and we are going to hear next from i
hope i pronounced this
correct this correctly is it sarab from
austin
uh hi i'm pacman yeah it's sauron
sarub okay uh what's going on uh
my question was regarding the minimum
wage sure why
does it have to be a fixed value why
can't be it be a dependent of couple of
factors
like the location as well as the
inflation rate
it absolutely can be i mean it's not the
way it's structured but i've i've
proposed this and i've said before that
um state by state there are dramatically
different costs of living
and and prevailing wages and what counts
as a livable wage
is very different in rural alabama
than it is in new york city so i think
there's a couple of different things and
you're on to some of them
one would be to index inflation is tough
because i don't i don't know that we
have
different inflation numbers by state
i've
i've only ever looked at national
inflation numbers so you could index the
minimum wage
in general to inflation but i
yeah don't know that one of the problem
that we have to keep updating
these value every five years or ten
years yes and it will
it won't put a pressure on uh small
businesses
if they won't have to increase just five
percent every year
the wage rather than it being a chunk
like
a couple of dollars or five dollars
after 10 years
no doubt no doubt i mean for me i think
the bigger differences would come
from adjusting the minimum wage based on
cost of living which is dramatically
different but then
here's a complicated question if a lot
of people
are working in one place but commuting
in from a different place
how do you account for that in terms of
is the cost of is the wage
adjusted to the cost of living where
they're working or where they're living
i mean there are things to figure out
but i think that you're absolutely
correct in that
in a country as large and economically
diverse as the united states
i think you need a baseline minimum wage
below which no state goes but more
more nuance is probably better in this
case
yeah i agree all right how are things in
austin these days
yeah it's pretty good the climate is
very nice right now
i bet all right very good i appreciate
the call
thank you my pleasure let's see who else
we want to hear from there are just
so many people eager to get on
let's go next to ethan from santa monica
ethan you're on the air
hey yeah can you hear me i can hear you
yeah
uh okay cool so i was wondering your
thoughts on the
for the people act and more specifically
the actions some democrats have been
proposing
to circumvent the filibuster remind me
which one is the for the p
i rarely know proposals by their names
yeah
that's hr1 oh hr hr1 okay yeah yeah of
course yeah okay
so obviously cinema and mansion have
said that they're
not going to get rid of the filibuster
as a whole yes
but the senate has amended it in the
past for budget reconciliation
right do you think the senate should
edit the filibuster
for quote-unquote democracy
reconciliation
so that only 50 votes are required in
order to pass
hr1 uh because i don't know don't know
if there's a better alternative
yeah i don't know and i've talked about
this before i think that
just doing away with the filibuster
uh changing from 60 to 50. i do believe
it's a double-edged sword and what we've
learned
is that these completely amoral
right wingers will use every tool they
have
against democrats when given the
opportunity and then they'll act
outraged when democrats do the same
thing a great example is the merrick
garland nomination in obama's last year
and then
putting amy covett barrett on the
supreme court within like a week or
whatever you know
they're just total hypocrites so the
question is
one do we quote stoop to their level
with the filibuster i don't have any
uh moral opposition however
i worry about how it would ultimately
come back to backfire dramatically
against democrats i think that
from what i've read i like the idea of
going back to it being
a real talking filibuster and requiring
40 people in the chamber at all times
in order to keep debate going this will
do two things it'll make it logistically
more difficult for republicans to keep
it up
and then number two uh it will also make
it more
publicly visible when republicans are
being obstructionists so
i'm kind of leaning in that direction
i've not seen like something super
convincing that says just blow up the
filibuster all together right now
well do you think that could actually
last
indefinitely because obviously right now
as it is
they can basically completely block hr1
from passing
and if they continue to like you know
if it's a talking filibuster obviously
the intention with that
is that uh they wouldn't be able to do
that indefinitely which is
sort of their whole point of the
filibuster yes uh
you're saying if that's what democrats
decided to do
in terms of a rule change couldn't
republicans then just undo that as well
next time they take control
exactly yeah they could but my point is
it might be a way
to get some things done now without
blowing it up all together which could
backfire dramatically
yeah i guess you know especially if if
they institute some sort of
50 vote alternative for uh democracy
reconciliation i think
you know if republicans somehow get a
trifecta they could
completely use that to you know add all
these
uh voting restrictions and all that
nationally so right
i guess it just depends on your sort of
philosophy per person
yeah and i'm also thinking about it from
a pragmatic standpoint which is
what are ways to get some things done
now without then
having disasters happen in the future in
an almost certain way and it's a
complicated thing i don't know the
answer i think
that what i feel strongly about though
is just leaving it the way it is now is
not likely to be the best outcome okay
all right thank you so much all right my
friend thank you great question very
very important topic and we'll be
uh a determining factor i would say in
what successes there are
in this first couple of years of joe
biden's presidency
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of
going into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully
there is a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video